[Music]
I've just touched down in Siem Reap in
remote northwest Cambodia it's home to
the renowned temples of Angkor Wat but
I'm on a different mission to discover
the secret of this country's fantastic
food Jesus I feel like I'm in the back
of beyond
I cannot believe there's something in
there hi this place seems so laid-back
Cambodia is a country in recovery in the
late 1970s the ruling Communist Party
the Khmer Rouge forced the population
into the countryside to live off the
land the result was a devastating famine
but today the nation is rediscovering
its culture and its food heritage how
many think of what it went through and
it became abolished really on the back
of the wall of the famine and everyone
forgot about it but it is starting to
see a revival so I can't wait to get the
grips with it get out there and really
understand what Carboni cuisine is all
about
thank God he's so small I'm starting my
education with a master class and
Cambodia's historic recipes from a chef
who is leading the country's food
Renaissance at a restaurant the sugar
palm I'm on my way to meet katana who's
all the best dressings in town if I'm
gonna get my hands dirty I can't think
of a better place to start
Kitana was exiled in new zealand 35
years ago when the Khmer Rouge ruled
Cambodia that's nice and busy
she returned seven years ago determined
to rediscover and celebrate traditional
dishes
Kitana what a beautiful place
thank you that looks amazing out there
so you were clearly at the forefront of
the revival of trying to I'm trying to
have you gone back to childhood dishes
in terms of yes that's what I'm trying
to do my mom and my grandmother recipe
trying to revise the tell me about to
1975 what actually happened to the food
in the war so people trying to stay to
survive so they could get whatever's
they could get the random from the
jungle or from anywhere they could find
and they just have to cook anything I
just couldn't imagine what sort of thing
they were each yeah to survive I think
that's why the food sort of gradually
disappear so katana is reviving
traditional authentic Cambodian recipes
the locals love it
it's a busy lunchtime service and I'm
going to learn on the job now we've got
order so first dishes from the clients
it's a fish among the first order in is
a classic one tablespoon of red pepper
it starts with karoon a spicy paste that
was used before the war
so it's not exactly healthy is it no as
long as you don't eat too much you'll be
fine holy this traditional recipe is far
more refined than I expected
and what kind of fish you use for mark
I'm using freshwater fishes called
snakehead and this is a tradition this
is what you watched your mother making
yes yes he quit always quite complex
isn't it the mixture is cooked in a palm
leaf
I'm gonna steam these now going to steam
this okay into the steamer excuse me
though Wow look at yours and the results
are fantastic
I'm amazed the way it's soo played up
that's delicious for a really nice soft
nice texture sweet texture it's like a a
red pepper fish souffle but you've got
the texture of the fish and the
sweetness without being overpowering
that's lovely
after years in the wilderness this
country's food is being put back on the
map I want my time here to do it justice
where do I need to go next to really
sort of get my fingers on the pulse and
really understand you should go to visit
the local home and the villagers and the
country size so you could go there and
have a look and see what those people do
I'm very grateful I'm amazing a big
eye-opener thank you very much it's good
to see